the most important thing is to know how
to diversify
well dumbest damn thing you could ever
buy in your life is a
big expensive luxury car if you own the
assets
and you don't go into debt
it really becomes a function of time
before you become fashionable again
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level of genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how billionaires
invest their money enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one diversify with ray dalio
the most important the investment
environment going forward will be very
different from the environment of the
past
i mean think about it as a zero and low
very low returning asset environment
because the liquidity
that's in the market is driving the
excess returns
of all markets down to be low in
relationship to the very low cash rate
so negative real returns not good for
cash until the most important thing
is to know how to diversify well and
what i mean by that
is to go beyond um the
just the traditional 60 40 stock bond
mix
or even the same countries um and to
broaden that diversification to include
in that portfolio
assets that might um um seem
um unusual to include some gold to
include
inflation index bonds to inclu to think
about the
currency exposure to think about safety
as different
most people think that cash is safe
cash is the least safe investment it
just doesn't have the same volatility to
it but it has
um because they're producing so much
cash it has a negative
real return it's a tax um that maybe two
percent a year you lose money in terms
of cash
so you have to think about risk
differently and you have to diversify
best that's the most important thing to
have
a well-diversified portfolio it's so the
uncertainties that we have today
are so great in terms of all the things
i mentioned the tax policies
the geopolitical certainly we must
experience it with the
virus you know will the next wave come
back and how will it be dear
diversification can be achieved without
reducing
your expected returns because of the way
that nature asset classes
are priced and then when if you're going
to take tactical bets
from those then those tactical bets
alpha
on top of that strategic
well-diversified portfolio
should have highly diversified uh bets
um deviated liquidity is going to be
more important than
before because things change in
unexpected ways
look at how in many of the cases the
businesses
that you one would have thought was a
good business and let's say you're in
private equity
and and that you're with that company
and so the restructuring the ability to
rebalance
and diversify and to make and to be
cautious
about making a highly diversified uh
set of bets um is i think the uh the
future but
thinking even of asset classes thinking
about
the value of money you know we look at
asset classes
and we say oh do i want my money to be
in stocks and which stocks
but we don't think about stocks bonds we
think about those traditional asset
classes
but we don't think about the value of
money and what's going to happen in
terms of the printing of that value of
the money
and how to diversifies it well so i
think those are the things
that have to be atta paid attention to
um in much
as they were important things in years
prior to 1945.
rule number two bet on banks with warren
buffett
seems like you've got a big waiting in
financials and of course you finally
invested
in jamie dimon's company why banks right
now
there are businesses i understand and i
like the price at which they're selling
relative to their future
prospects i think 10 years from now that
they'll be worth more money
and i feel it's a there's a very high
probability i'm right
and i don't think they'll turn out to be
the best investments at all
of you know the whole the whole panoply
of things you could do
but i'm pretty sure that they won't
disappoint me rule number three
don't make dumb purchases with grant
cardone
this car right here this rolls
royce wraith with freaking
magic the magic astrological
zodiac sign built into the ceiling with
little sparkles
dumbest damn thing you could ever buy in
your life is a
big expensive luxury car in fact okay in
my rant today i want to share with you
one of the things that i did smart in my
life was i never bought these exotic
cars that everybody seems to go out and
buy as soon as they make a little money
what i did was this i waited i waited
and i waited
to ever do a dumb thing like this dumb
one of the dumbest things i've ever
bought in my damn life
okay i waited until number one
i didn't have to buy one and number two
until it didn't matter
i just got my financial statement in
three months the first three months of
this year compared to last year
a double a double you understand what a
double is
a double means i can do stupid now okay
look once you make enough money to where
you can blow
461 000 and it don't matter
then go do it okay until then
until then do not waste your money
i'm sorry this car was only 384 thousand
dollars
i didn't want to exaggerate to you but i
think they added some stuff to this bad
boy
so look until then until then
until then don't waste your money on
watches
and cars and brinyo brione
suits okay it's ridiculous you guys that
are buying 1200
shoes stupid you guys that are buying
200 000 cars
stupid you guys are spending money on
homes no offense but you're
stupid you don't need an expensive house
you don't need a country club yet
what you need is paper you need money
baby
you need net worth you need passive
income you need
flows baby flows and flows and flows
you don't need a roll of choice hey man
how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number four own
assets with thomas kaplan you were
starting your own company but what
expertise did you have to start your own
company in the business world
i had no expertise okay um
and there was really no reason
to give me any banking
fortunately my first foray was in silver
in 1993 and the zeitgeist was that
silver was going to go down to two
dollars because digital film would
supplant silver halide
um i believe that people got the
analysis wrong and that silver had a
better chance of going back to 50.
so i put my money on silver options
and silver went from three and a half to
five and a half dollars in
relatively short order and i made enough
money
to decide that i didn't want to do that
anymore but i would take all that money
and put that when buying an option on a
silver property
well let me make sure i understand uh
where did you get the money to buy the
options
i started with ten thousand dollars okay
so i had you know a little bit of
savings
and turned that into hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and then put the money on a um
on a property in idaho um
and i realized around that time that i
really didn't have very much competition
and so i took whatever money i had and i
went to peru
and bolivia and mexico and i would put
down
options on these properties after a
certain period of time i found that i
had as interesting a portfolio
of option properties as any existing
silver company
and i knew that even though i wasn't
ready for prime time
even though the story was
uh a little bit flaky and delusional a
new york-based financial type with no
background in engineering
or geology starting a mining company
um i kept it low-key but i was
introduced
to george soros and he and his brother
paul
invested in me and how old were you at
this time
i was 32
33 okay and you were married then
i was engaged gage and did your fiance
say
what do you do for a living oh no no no
she was instrumental
in the entire process when i had the
the vision of buying silver mines
it was in the middle of the night and
she was at nyu she left the israeli air
force and
was studying at nyu
and apparently at three o'clock in the
morning i sat up in bed
and said please write this down so i
don't forget it buy silver mines
and so the next day daphne said to me by
the way last night
you told me to write down buy silver
mines so i'm reminding you
but i'm also going to add this that is
so sexy
and so i went to the silver business wow
so
she has unerring um insight
okay so how did it work out i found that
it suited my aptitudes to take that
money
and buy assets
and hold those assets having a
historical bent
allowed me to see the market through the
prism of history
and so when you see these cycles
and you understand human psychology and
fear and greed
the history gives you a great
perspective and so if you own the assets
and you don't go into debt um
it really becomes a function of time
before you become fashionable again
and we made a huge discovery in bolivia
and that's where the fortune originated
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is invest in bitcoin with kathy wood
what's been interesting this time around
is to if you look at google search
trends
for bitcoin or bitcoin's price uh
against the bitcoin
price itself um you'll find that there's
not a lot of speculative activity by
that measure
in fact in 2017 they were one for one
together
but it has been pretty quiet until maybe
very recently but throughout last year
and so that gave us a lot of comfort
we believe that the institutional
behavior
uh and moves recently have been
fascinating we have been expecting
institutions to start moving into
bitcoin
and other crypto assets but primarily uh
bitcoin the most secure
of the blockchains um because
uh because it if you look at the
correlation of bitcoin's performance
relative to any other asset class
it is it has the lowest correlation
meaning if you buy some bitcoin you will
further diversify your portfolio
and increase your returns with lower
risk
right so that's why institutions look
for that low correlation
bitcoin has it and so
that's clear we have 10 years of history
now
but what surprised me and us generally
was to watch microstrategy which has put
all of its all the cash on its balance
sheet into bitcoin
and even did another equity offering so
it could put more cash on its balance
and i i think that's a little crazy
because i i think the regulators will
have something to say about this
in terms of what is this is this company
the microstrategy technology company or
is it like an etf so we don't know about
that
but then you saw square put one percent
of
all of its assets in bitcoin and i think
you're going to see more of that
we didn't expect that what we did expect
was because of the low correlation of
returns
uh institutional investors to move in
the most surprising one to me thus far
has been mass mutual it put a hundred
million dollars
into its general account now its general
account
is enormous so a hundred million dollars
is something like
point zero zero one but what what that
move told us is you know mass mutual's
very conservative and very highly
regulated
uh and so it had to jump through many
more regulatory hurdles
uh than i thought would have been
possible by now
uh so i think that uh is a seal of
approval
and then of course you have the
institutional infrastructure moving into
into place whether it's with custody
and everyone uh knows a lot about
fidelity being
out there in terms of uh wanting to
custody
bitcoin in particular you have the
intercontinental exchange
uh and uh and you've got the cme now
with bitcoin futures uh one settling in
uh kind one settling in cash uh
and so uh we do believe that
uh bitcoin is getting ready for
institutional but
when we when we actually think about
this
uh is bitcoin ready for institutions
bitcoin is only it's roughly
a 600 billion dollar market cap so
not even half the size of apple or
amazon right doesn't put it into
perspective
and yet it is a very big idea i think a
much bigger idea
than uh apple or amazon it's the first
global truly global digital currency out
there and
it it is completely decentralized
there's no
throat to choke now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i have over 50
private companies i'm an investor in
across america practically every state
and every sector i do everything from
workout equipment to greeting cards to
technology
i do dna testing i mean there's just so
many different businesses i'm in
and it's all been empowered by
technology when we had the beginning of
the pandemic and retail basically shut
down
my company's lost you know significant
amount of
momentum because majority or if you look
at any mid cap
company 50 of its revenue comes from
retail
and that's a 50 cent dollar margin
business and then usually 40
with amazon and 10 from their own
website that's the classic mix
and so when you lose 50 of your revenue
has happened in late march
uh they had to pivot so they started
buying shopify licenses they bought
docusign licenses they bought microfiber
microsoft standardization they used
wix.com to enrich the
you know experience on their websites
they went to logistics with um
facebook shop and walmart and so they
they created
an alternative to retail distribution at
100 cents on the dollar margin when
you're selling direct your customer
and that happened right across the
portfolio and so the companies that
empowered all that are the internet
giants of the world it's not just the
fangs
some of the names i just rattled off
wix.com they're not all american
companies there's a global focus on
e-commerce and it's we're only in the
third inning on that i mean it's
these stocks technology will continue to
lead the market
probably the next three to five years
that's what i think uh
it's changing the entire economy and
accommodating the fact that you know
we're in this horrible pandemic without
technology we would have really been
screwed
but here we have a way to actually
conduct business online digitally
direct to our customers and we are
flourishing i prefer to own a broader
portfolio
than just the fangs because this
phenomenon is
worldwide it's not just north american
and as conor just detailed
some of the mid-sized companies are
growing faster than the fangs and the
valuation on
internet giants really has to do with
sales growth
you know if you had said all the pe for
amazon is too high 10 years ago
you would have missed out on thousands
of percent increase in court in value
so you don't necessarily value tax just
on earnings it's a factor
but sales growth is far more important
and so
indexing like an ogi connor mansion
that's what i use i own that
it's got over 70 names instead of just
four including the fans
[Music]
if you want to learn how to invest like
a billionaire check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there that's a high paying
skill set to have it's the most
important thing that you could start off
doing
it's more difficult to succeed in the
markets
than it is to succeed in the olympics